[Music]
i cherish peace with all my heart
i don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
to me peacemaker he's the saddest
character in the whole thing he has the
most difficulty connecting to another
human being because he doesn't feel like
he belongs i think liberty's just your
excuse to do whatever you want we talked
a lot about backstory james is like hey
man be like a douchey captain america
who would shoot a kid
okay i got it
peacemaker
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection no
peacemaker's a lot of guys i grew up
with it's just a rash that's a rash i
mean he is this sort of dude bro
like a lot of dude bros he didn't have a
great father didn't have any mother his
father was a soldier who trained her son
how to kill from the moment he was born
bloodsport it's like i'm the leader
peacemaker's like you're the leader i
always hear my talk is dead center get
them more in the center
it's toxic masculinity at its most toxic
he just wants to be
seen and there's like a lot of
psychological subtext there as well
you're laughing at me for him tightly
whitey's really nah that's just racist
how sad is he that he feels like he's an
outsider in any room that he sits in
that he is desperate to be dominant
because he doesn't feel like he belongs
you see it when he's sitting in the
background of the bus as the other
characters are talking and he doesn't
say a word he's very socially awkward
something as simple as the uniform hits
on the head that this guy has validation
problems no one likes to show off unless
what they're showing off as dope as
if you're doing covert ops you wear
something like idris character you try
not to be seen this is a guy who wears a
large chrome helmet everything is red
white blue and yellow this man genuinely
thinks he's a hero and wants his
peacemaker logo on everything
every time i look over at john and he's
wearing that silver toilet on his head
it's not a toilet seat it's a beacon of
freedom ah it's the best you know it's
so ridiculous these are the moments
gentlemen drink them in john cena caught
me so unexpectedly i mean people think
his superpower is that he's super strong
and he's a good actor but his ability to
make us all laugh is his superpower
john cena is the best improv artist i've
ever worked with in my life and i've
worked with a lot of comedians head to
the second floor shower stall three
sixteen hundred and thirty hours his
name's felipe but they call him the
bloodhound i'm looking into the shower
deep while we've been shooting he's been
teaching himself how to play piano
that's crazy to me he's an alien
and he's like the hugest person i've
ever seen in my life the thing that was
most difficult was learning to sword
fight
in high heels
peacemaker's not really as tall as you
think he is
to be able to humanize his character
fully and get to the bottom of who he is
and what makes him the way he is is what
drove me to do the tv show with him what
do you guys want him for just to save
the world that's all
and that kind of let loose this
odd character we have and i think
there's a lot of shades of grey with
these characters and the same thing with
peacemaker and his lofty ideals keeping
the peace is worth any price i'm excited
about having them appear in movies and
in tv i'm having an amazing time doing
peacemaker on hbo max
[Music]
you